I am really looking forward to Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy and not because
I'm some kind of furry who's erotically
obsessed with space raccoons seriously
I'm really not the mask oh i just bought
the mask of the video honest i'm looking
forward to this new comic book
adaptation because it takes place in a
distant corner of the galaxy marvel
studios president of production called
it more of a standalone film than the
other entries in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe ah standalone that word is
music to my ears you see comic book
movies have become far too interwoven
and enmeshed The Avengers hands a story
the time to iron man 3 which hands a
baton to thor the dark world which hands
a baton to Captain America Winter
Soldier now in a way that's crafty each
movie functions is a commercial for the
next one and you have to buy tickets for
all of them if you want to follow the
overarching story but it also means that
every Marvel movie essentially serves as
a prequel for the next entry and that is
very bad because prequels are an
inherently sketchy enterprise I mean
when I watch it oz the great and
powerful or Prometheus or Phantom Menace
I just sit there wishing that i was
watching wizard of oz or alien or the
original Star Wars you know better
movies and this prequel ization play has
infected other comic book franchises to
just look at the amazing spider-man 2
the central storyline got completely
overshadow sorry Jamie Foxx you deserved
better the main reason it was so lousy
and it was just accepted is that it
spent so much time laying the ground
works for amazing spider-man 3 all of
these movies should look to empire
strikes back for it
operation it was a bridge yes it set up
the events a return of the jedi but it
also had merit as a standalone fill you
got Leia's deepening relationship with
han you've got Luke training with Yoda
and then ignoring his advice to go save
his friends you've got Lando's betrayal
and partial Redemption the best way to
make me want to see the next movie in
your franchise isn't with foreshadowing
and post credits teasers it's by
actually getting me emotionally invested
in the characters and events of the
current installment in your franchise
that I am watching right now some people
say that guardians of the galaxy looks
too wacky that it's nothing more than a
big budget version of spaceballs
everybody got that I say we should be so
lucky let me know the name of your
favorite sci-fi comedy in the comments
and subscribe to the wire channel